on reste encore dans le monde de l'image
pour évoquer l'espoir déçu de folimage
les studios de valence avait été nominée
pour un oscar à los angeles
mais la nuit dernière leur film
d'animation le moine et le poisson n'a
rien ramené dans ses filets
comme dans une chanson de geste ce film
conte l'histoire d'une impossible
conquête le mois des poissons c'est un
peu don quichotte en robe de bure du pré
vert en animations sipho l'image n'aura
pu rêver d'hollywood que le temps d'une
nuit des oscars
le fait d'avoir été sélectionné déjà en
soi une formidable consécration
consécration d'une aventure qui démarre
exactement voilà dix ans à valence ou
créer un studio de dessin animé n'avait
rien d'évident
dix ans plus tard folimage c'est une
cinquantaine de dessinateurs de
décorateurs d'opérateurs un chiffre
d'affaires de plus de 10 millions de
francs et surtout une entreprise qui
fournit des programmes d'animation aux
chaînes de télévision de 35 pays
différents
c'est même une entreprise qui se paye le
luxe d'être une sorte de mécènes en
matière de création de dessins animés en
accueillant deux réalisateurs étrangers
par an on accueille c'est ces gens à
passer de projets on leur paye le film
techniquement humainement et
financièrement on paye le film et
michael dunlop de witte a fait ce film
là dans ce cadre là donc là aussi c'est
une reconnaissance internationale de
cette résidence qui était un projet qui
dépasse pas facile au départ et qui
maintenant est bien rodée là
aucun des ses lettres de noblesse en
quelque sorte bien sûr folimage n'est
pas walt disney mais ici chacun peut
poursuivre une forme de rêve éveillé
tout en conservant sa totale liberté de
création
jamais tu te dire que c'est un peu nos
danseuses des courts métrages
au fond c'est plus qu'une danseuse et
notre âme notre véritable âme faire des
recherches dans le court métrage et
défend de cinéma d'auteur c'est pour
nous la chose fondamentale folimage est
devenue une pme de l'imaginaire ou
l'acier et le fer sont capables de
devenir poèmes
bien sûr ici on aurait préféré avoir
l'oscar du meilleur court métrage
d'animation plutôt que ne pas l'avoir
mais on est sûr que de toute façon la
nuit dernière à loudes
il s'est passé quelque chose de très
important qui éclaire l'avenir de
l'entreprise revenus